And here is my solution. These are two update
lines. They’re basically identical except one
goes in one direction and the other direction.
Let’s look at the first; we have an update
weight over here. We add two times our
new constraint with the index I minus 1. This
is the subtract part. We subtract I minus 2 and
we subtract the original on the right side over
here. It’s exactly the math I’ve given you.
Same over here. If you won this math , you
get this new smooth curve. I should warn you,
this can be unstable, it can give you results that
are very poor you have to adjust these parameters
very carefully and this is one of many ways to
smooth. There is many other ways to smooth,
but the nice thing that you achieve here is that
you get actually smooth two points that they
are holding fixed, which is actually
really, really useful.